نتواجد حاليا في شرق محافظه جده شهاده
مدينه جده بكافه مناطقها شمالا وجنوبا
وشرقا وغربا امطار من متوسطه الى غزيره
منذ صباح اليوم وتحديدا في تمام الساعه
8:00 صباحا ولا زال تستمر حتى الان اذا
وصلت مستويات هطول الامطار الى 60 مللي
متر شهدتها محافظه جده اغلاق العديد من
الشوارع والامفاق والمخارج الرئيسيه
تتحدثنا على الشريان الرئيسي لمدينه
لمدينه محافظه جده وتحديدا طريق الحرمين
الذي يربط بين مكه وجده تم اغلاقه خلال
الساعه الماضيه وكذلك
اغلاق شوارع وطرق رئيسيه
وشارع الستين وكذلك انفاق شارع فلسطين في
جده كل هذه الانفاق شلت تماما وتمت عبيت
بالمياه بالكامل لاسيما انه هنالك تصريف
في هذه الانفاق المستحدثه ولكن حجم المياه
طول هطول الامطار لم تستوعب هذه همم فوق
قنوات التصريف داخل هذه الانفاق حجم هذه
المياه الكبيره اتحدثنا مع الدفاع المدني
الذي اخبرنا بان كامل الفرق الميدانيه
تعمل
لانقاذ الحالات المحتجزه داخل المركبات
وتحديدا داخل الانفاق وتتحدثنا كذلك عن
حالات الماسه الكهربائيه تعمل الفرق
الميداليه واللجانه المشكله بين الفرق
الدفاع المدني وكافه القطاعات الامنيه
وكذلك القطاعات الصحيه وشركه الكهرباء
والمياه وايضا امانه جده التي تعمل
بالياتها في كافه الشوارع الرئيسيه
لسحب المياه داخل الانفاق تحديدا والينا
ناخذكم في لقطات تتواجد حاليا في حي
النخيل وتحديدا في هذه المنطقه نتواجد في
الجهه المقابله تحديدا فاطمه يتواجد مجرى
السيول امتلى بالكامل كما نشاهد منسوب
المياه عاد بشكل كبير ااه جدا شله يعني
شله الحركه بشكل كبير في كافه الشرايين
الرئيسيه بمدينه جده يتحدث على الخط
السريع وشارع ال70 و60 وال 40 وكذلك الخط
الرابط بمطار الملكه الدولي وايضا كافه
الاحياء اكثر الاماكن تضررا همم في جده
مناطق شرق جده وجنوب جده وتحديدا بسبب
السيول المنقوله الاسير من هذه المناطق
ليس بها يعني قنوات تسريب او مجاري تصريف
كبيره تستوعب حجم هذه المياه ايضا نوهت
نوها الدفاع المدني بشكل مباشر مع
التواصلنا معه قبل ساعه من الان ان جاري
من قبل الفرقه الدفاع المدني تعمل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه من خلال انقاذ المحتجزين
ومباشره حالات الماس الكهربائيه والتيار
الكهربائي داخل المنازل ايضا نوهت همم
المرور هو كذلك عبر حساباته ان تم اغلاق
عدد كبير من الشوارع وطلب من المواطنين
والموقنين ان يطقوا في منازلهم حتى انتهاء
هذه الحاله المطريه التي سوف تستمر الى
حتى تمام الساعه الثالثه همم ظهرا بحسب
ال- ال- النشره الجويه التي عملت عليها
ارصاد وحمايه البيئه